what is depreciation you should have
like a nice one sentence definition of
it in your minds how would you define it
loss of value good what's the value
which should not surprise you because as
you already know about me by now i'm
really into words and what they mean and
why right so look at what this word
looks like right
um
d e when you see that as a prefix on the
front of anything like say
deduct
or demote right what's that about or
decrease it's about things going down
right
um some kind of drop
things are shifting right and then of
course what's that word in the middle
where does that come from do you
recognize it
p art i know it's um we've substituted a
vowel which makes it a little harder to
recognize but clearly that comes from
price doesn't it which by the way is not
where it ends right where does price
come from
comes from something which is which is
valuable namely
a prize okay so that's where it comes
from this idea of things that you value
but you're bringing them down okay so to
prize something is to to value it which
is why a price is
its value as a um as a noun okay
now why are we looking at depreciation
under the topic of cars why is that
important
why do cars depreciate
can think of at least two reasons two
main ones
yep
good
so
as they get used right they get damaged
they get dings all that kind of thing
right so that makes sense any other
reasons what if you don't use it all
that much just leave it in garage does
it still depreciate yeah it does why
yeah fantastic okay so just as things
get older right often they're going to
become less valuable it's worth
mentioning by the way they don't always
do they right not all cars depreciate
over time what what kinds of cars don't
depreciate
yeah like really um
yeah good so they're kind of like you
know age right if it becomes like an
antique in fact the older something is
the more values it doesn't depreciate it
appreciates right so so you've got to be
careful with that one
but for us right we're mostly dealing
with and purchasing cars that are going
to depreciate right
now you should remember there are two
kinds of depreciation right
miss marshall what's the shade
where i'm going okay
let me look you up
lucky
you're going to
eleven empty two three which from
memories in
b126 okay
okay
as you were saying there are two kinds
of depreciation what are they they have
special names as well do you remember
where they are
okay so you've got linear right or or
sort of straight
sorry
straight line depreciation
which means that every year what's
happening to the value of your car it's
just gonna lose the same amount
five thousand dollars five thousand
dollars five thousand dollars okay
before we go into a bit more detail on
that and remember why right what's the
other kind if it's not straight line if
it's not
okay good so percentage right
and the other 15 before it is declining
balance
okay yes it should be there but i'm
trying to make sure that you really
understand and not just have it there
sort of thought away okay now
based on the fact that how these
mathematically work what's our formula
for each one it starts with s4
doesn't remember what that stands for
salvage value good how do we work it out
for straight line depreciation
okay good so you start with your initial
value they usually call it v naught
right so not as in time no time is
passed right
minus because you're depreciating minus
what
okay so whatever constant i think i just
said five thousand dollars right
multiplied by
however long you've been doing it for n
years right so that's fine right
percentage or decline bounce right it
works quite differently s equals now it
still does start with v naught but what
happens now
okay so we need some brackets in here
what's inside the brackets
okay one minus now instead of a d right
we don't call it d because not the same
amount every time it's a
percentage right a rate
and
to the power of n which we ought to of
course recognize because really
this is this is just compound interest
in reverse right uh whoops that's wrong
we're used to this
exactly the same kind of thing right
you've got to make sure you get the
connections
now quick question let's see this is not
within the textbook but
you should know it because this is where
you're heading in life i assume if you
get money and all that
why
would you choose one over another like
you can calculate both but when do you
use one when do you do the other do you
discuss that at all
okay so so when would you use linear
um
okay so they're going to be decreasing
at a constant rate right now i guess i
would ask you this question if we know
that it's decreasing the same amount of
every year who would want to do that
what kind of people
would want to calculate the depreciation
like this do you know the answer does
anyone know the answer
okay so
um
dealerships is one example but i want to
be a little bit broader than that really
and that's a good answer by the way
really it's any company any company
any large organization that has to work
out depreciation for a large number of
objects over a large period of time okay
here's the reason why
let's just think about dealerships since
that's what was the example how many
cars do you think an average dealership
has has access to and has to think about
the money for
ballpark figure
just picture a dealership in your mind
like how many cars do you think that is
hmm maybe 30 if it's a small one
100 if it's a big one and by the way
it's not just the ones that are there
that they have access to there's lots
more that's that they also have to
manage the accounts for right so maybe
maybe you've got like say a hundred
different cars okay and if you think
about
um each of the different cars they all
have different values some of them might
be you know special fancy cars or
something like that but the point is
they're all depreciating at different
rates okay who has to do that who has to
work out all of this stuff
probably in a few years some of you guys
if you become accountants right
there will be a finance department right
and they maybe hire a few clerical staff
and it's their job to work out for every
one of those cars how much are they
going to be worth right now if they're
going to do it this way it's a pain it's
confusing it's a lot of clerical work
right so it's simpler mathematically to
do it this way even though it's more
accurate mathematically to do it this
way
okay
so if that's why you would choose linear
why would you choose
declining balance why would you choose a
percentage
this this is starting to get more you
guys rather than these why would you
personally do it that way
yeah does it decrease far less when you
get older okay so if i think about the
life of the car right this is what a
graph
of declining balance looks like right
and we'll have a look at some of these
in your textbook okay so clearly sorry
that should be you know
you start somewhere right clearly you're
losing all that value at the beginning
okay so you drop like a rock
for for these first few years right and
then it kind of tapers off like you look
at this period over here you don't lose
all that much value right and
interestingly even though it sounds like
where you want it where you want to get
benefit is over here it's like oh i
don't lose too much value
actually the reason why you guys and me
would choose declining balance is
precisely
because this drop in value why is it
actually good
to have a drop in value on your records
for the things you own
think about it
think about all the maths you've been
doing this year and what it applies to
where might it actually be useful
to lose value depreciate
faster why why would you want it yeah
for insurance okay let's think about
this
insurance
the more valuable your stuff is right
the more you have to pay to insure it
okay so there's one factor right it is
true it's not the main one i'll give you
a bit of a hand
tax we spent a long time looking at
taxes here right
deductions for tax what's a deduction is
a deduction
and can you give me an example
like i earn this amount of money okay
and then i want to say look i shouldn't
pay tax on all of that right i'm gonna
i'm gonna knock off some right why for
what reasons would you deduct
things from your taxable income come on
you know some of them think about them
for work fantastic so for example
suppose i buy a car right and i've got a
value and i'm like look i drive this for
work
i need this car so you shouldn't tax me
on that income right i had to buy that
car in order to do my job all right
now therefore see this big drop in value
okay this depreciation
you can claim that as a tax deduction
right so obviously you and me we want
this number to be as big as possible
right the more i have lost the more i've
had to expend to keep this car right the
more i can claim off my tax right so why
do people do this
make your work easier right why do
people do this
so that they can get a bigger tax refund
at the end of the financial year okay
and almost certainly this is what you
will do or you'll get your accountant to
do if they're any good okay